what a deal this is cross from Oklahoma
I work there for your show at the Tower
Theatre in a year and it was amazing oh
thank you brother yeah in Oklahoma man's
beautiful area over there and one of the
managers at the Comedy Store this
gentleman Curtis Nelson is an Oklahoman
and he's uh probably wanted top 60 or 70
decent men I've known Oh word and I'm
sitting here watching this past weekend
at my house
I'm just curious uh you give a lot of
credit to your higher power and to be
honest you sound like with the way you
talk you sound like you're uh you
believe in Jesus you believe in God
so I'll just wondering how come you
don't say God whatever you say your
higher power or do you just not believe
in necessary of God and that there is
just a higher power
anyways men keep doing you getting
better love you gang game bro love you
back playboy uh you know sometime I say
higher power um you know my god isn't
like a real name maniac some gods is a
real name maniac you know call me it is
call me they call me Henry you know but
um you know I believe in God man and I
know I know some people don't that's
fine with me you know I think I ever God
is a personal choice and for me I think
I need a God I don't do the best job of
believing in him sometimes I know a lot
of times I'd say I do my home will but
you know I just think it's rip it's it's
taking a chance man it's taking a chance
to believe in God you know to say that
there's something out there because
sometimes in my brain I can't I don't
want the best for myself you know as sad
as that is to say or as hard as that is
to say sometimes uh you know sometimes I
don't want you know I'll just be how
either to be feeling depressed or it's
not good or just
I don't know or just you know sometimes
I just don't I don't want the best for
myself in some ways I can't even explain
it really mm-hmm
sometimes it's easier for me to expect
not good things to happen because then
I'll be able to say oh I told you so you
know it's easier for me to expect you
know to try and like I don't know
examine I know what I'm trying to say
just sometimes it's hard for me it's
been hard for me this past year to
really connect to some of my feelings
but I believe in it I believe in God man
I believe in a higher power and it's a
God of my understanding and I believe
that you can have your own relationship
with God I believe that and for me I'm
glad that it's there because it's
fascinating to me sometimes that even
when I don't care about you know
sometimes when I don't care about myself
I don't have the strength or the you
know it's it's it's it's amazing to
believe that somebody does you know that
something out there really does want the
best for me and that to me that's God
you know I believe that God wants the
best for me and that's scary to think
really because a lot of my life you know
I think growing up and you know just in
my and I'm not and look I'm not feeling
sorry for myself right now P I'm not
being hard on myself I'm just trying to
share my feelings and talk on something
I'm not having self-pity right now I'm
just trying to share my feelings
you know believing believing in a higher
power is scary out there it's risky and
most of my life you know I felt like God
like God didn't care I felt like God
didn't care about me if I'm real honest
or it was just way easier for me to
admit to myself to say to myself Oh God
doesn't love me you know God doesn't
love me but the older I get and just the
more like just little blessings that I
see you know it could be a smile and
somebody you know it could be somebody
answering the phone when I called them
somebody who I don't even think I don't
know man it can be it could be times
even when I don't want to spend time
with someone and I choose to because I
know it's what they need I'm not trying
to say that in a selfish way but just
you know I don't even want to make the
choice be like aw to do that and and
then something will come over me and say
oh I know I need to do this on it's not
about me yeah that and there's just too
many of those coincidences eventually
we're you know I just have to admit that
that there's I believe that there's
something out there that wants to see me
that wants me to know that it loves me
[Music]
and that's you know that's you know cuz
a lot of my life I felt either unloved
or unlovable you know or uh or I just
felt like I didn't care about others I
don't know I just I don't know man a lot
of it's a new relationship for me and
it's one that I'm trying to just try my
best with um and I don't have any of the
answers but for me to believe that
something that doesn't even know me
really has always loved me like really
loved me man like loved me no matter
what I did you know that's to me that's
that's pretty that's that's a power
stronger than anything I could do so I
kind of don't know what I'm talking
about but III say my god because I think
that different people have different
gods different people have their own
gods I don't you know I don't I don't
get into God fights that's not my thing
you know and and also I don't know man I
have no idea but I appreciate you
calling and asking and uh and be good
bro be good out there you know
[Music]
you know sometimes it's just so it's so
hard for me sometimes to love somebody
else you know I'll use like I'll use my
care like my ability to care about
others I use that in relationships you
know I've used that before as like a
weapon sometimes like I'll keep like
I've kept my care away from somebody
like even though maybe I love somebody I
kept my care I kept you know I like I
used my care as like a weapon like oh
you know you know I just I would love to
one day be able to be in a place where
my love and care for others isn't on a
like a scale type of basis you know
isn't on uh isn't on any type of
exchange basis at all you know or that I
don't like I mean I would just I would
love to be able to you know I think I I
think that one day I would like to be
able to love somebody no matter what you
know cuz that's how you know that's how
that's how you know that's how I would
like to be loved probably by someone and
I've never really been able to do that
[ __ ] I never really have felt examples
of that and stuff growing up and look
I'm not having self-pity I'm not [ __ ]
down in the dumps right now I'm not
being hard on myself I'm just trying to
share things that I think are things
that I'm thinking about you know I know
I'm hard on myself a lot people always
come up to me to show them and I'll be
throwing yourself I know I am you know
sometimes it's the only way that I've
ever known to be dog thank you guys for
checking out this clip and if you want
to see another clip then you can look at
this clip or this clip either one of
these so did you pick one or he's still
just watching me do this
is alarming